okay so the shape of coffee Dosa so
kokidosa is a Micro Drone
it's
it's going to isolate out
several of the elements that make up
larger drills quinoa
okay so you're just going to focus in on
a few things that you use all the time
in kihon Wasa okay
um like any micro drill or any drill
as you get better
you can do it any number of ways and you
should you should not be restricted to
the one way okay that's why you have
different levels of training so you'll
have like Q one was a training you'll
have GG was a training for example
but at the beginning level there's a
shape you should have the shape you
should do only that
okay
um so let's look at the shapes we went
over so far one we had the hand shape
and we had the arm shape so I'm going to
use the hand shape
and I'm going to only use the arm shapes
at kihon level
so some of you here you don't you don't
have that shape yet I wouldn't venture
out and start doing whatever
so I only have the inward spiral and
then the outward spiral
and the art is based in yin yang Theory
so just as a side note again you don't
need to know the theory behind anything
to do the shape
but one hand is going to be young and
one hand is going to be Yin
and by concentric extension one hand is
doing I key one hand is doing Coq the
yin hand does I key and the young hand
does coke you
just as in the in the symbol there is a
little of its opposite in its field so
the ike hand the yin hand has a little
Coq
and the Coq hand the young hand has a
little eye key
remember the young hand is the is the
inward pattern and the yin hand is the
outward pattern
so we're going to use the hand shape the
arm shape as in this drill
now we'll introduce the next basic thing
you always want
and that is uh kazushi
now kazushi
in aikida is a particular thing at
kihonawaza yes it is a disequilibrium in
their balance yes
but because you have a specific arm
shape a specific waza shape uh we
mentioned that it is always going to be
a tilt of their spine
it will never be
uh their spine leaning forward leaning
backwards or crunching
is that a disequilibrium yes but not
it's not the one we want in kihon Wasa
they're always going to tilt they're
always going to tilt okay they can tilt
to the front corner the front corner the
back corner or the back corner that's
where you're always going to go okay so
you want to look for that in your
kokudosa so for you here some of you
never get the Tilt in the person okay
all right
so
we'll go this way will be my young hand
which again is the inward spiral
this one's the yin head
so last video
we did a drill from here
immersed spiral and we came back and we
did the outward spiral okay
one more time
inward
outward
so that grid on my chest will still
apply
my elbow never goes outside that
shoulder line
stays in and it's going to pass that mid
chest line
come to the Midway point the elbow
and I use my body
and it comes back
that long line that shoulder line comes
down midline
midline here on my elbow and then
out
so in kokidosa that's the young hand
young hand boom
if we look at kazushi and we look at her
spine I'm going to tilt it
the in hand
the yin hand is going to
go inside
so my elbow is going to come in
and then on the outside
and then yield
you can see again it's going to tilt her
spine
what I don't want is two young hands
you see you see that she's she let stay
there but let go she's perfectly
balanced okay
so at the same time this hand goes
Yang the sound goes Yin
don't I'm not doing this
there's a spiral
in my hands
I am still working the patterns
so kokudosa
is just this drill
that we did
from yote working the two hands at the
same time
Okay so
Yong Yin tilt
okay so we had a question here it's it's
a common question
um it goes back to the first video I
only have these two shapes I only have
the the uh Yang or the fire hand and the
water and the yin hand that's all I have
I don't have this stuff that you you
commonly see or your arms go like I
called it robot hands or The Leverage
seeking I don't have those in quinoa
okay
um
I get what I want with those vectors
by doing different things with my body
at different times okay so for example
the yin hand is the outward spiral
of of this drill you see
there it's clearly obvious what I was
doing because you're thinking
two-dimensionally and there you go Coke
you whole okay
but you can make the pattern uh you can
shrink it you can have a a big heart so
a big heart
well you can have a little heart
okay
and if I don't stay in this plane
I can achieve different things with this
okay so as I move my body you see
and I make a small heart
boom here imagine her little head down
low
over here you see there's your cookie
hole
if I do a little heart move my body
it's duplicating
what appears to be a straight line
so we'll do it on this side okay so I'm
going to move my body
and
move my body
so if you watch my shoulder as a
reference point or you can watch my
chest
or my center it's going to rotate
that is important because I don't make
my hand go out like this and back which
you do by leaving your shoulder in place
so my shoulders in place my arms going
out and my hands are back
that's gonna work your outer and rear
deltoid which are inferior muscle groups
so instead my elbow anchors
and that's it
I don't
use my hand
so here is the conflict
I reconcile it boom and then my body
goes around it
he pushes
I reconcile at home I'm on the inside
and now my body moves
and
with your shoulder as a reference point
or a point of articulation
around
different
same goes on the young hand
okay
she if I were to make a completely
two-dimensional inward spiral like I'm
drawing a heart on a chalkboard and I
leave my chest still you get something
different and most importantly
you get your inner deltoid working
but my body's gonna move
so
you see that the shoulder hasn't
articulated
here or bring the elbow under
then around
she has the conflict dinner she's going
going come on give me some muscle come
on okay boom
so I
risk uh reconcile the conflict boom
there it's off
boom
my hand is it
tracing around my shoulder
this is important
because
I have
young energy Yin energy
um
and the source of this energy is my
Tanda and my Hara
so using the traditional Concepts I have
Yang Chi and I have yinchi and but the
source of this Chi uh has to pass
through uh circulate and emanate out
from my heart up
okay so as a side note here you're in
essence you can see there's a kind of
tenchy nugget to the technique you see
so we stand up
because you're lost and she Noggin
one hand's in one hand's Young
and you're you are in the middle of it
okay
so I uh I would like for you to watch my
center now and that will help you
understand that my shoulders my chest
never stay in the same plane and my arms
are articulating around my shoulders
okay
so you watch how much my Center moves
because I am going to circulate
this yin and yang energy
inside
my body
foreign
to do that
and when I'm not seeing you guys do here
and it's very common
you have to bring into the training your
zazen mine
you cannot sit here and go
heart sheep
Elba
it's too intellectual
so you enter
into that same coordination and again
this is not the shape of kokidosa but
the inside of cookie Dosa okay the shape
we just we already did
but to do the inside of kokidosa the ego
tripartite mind and the god mind must
also be in that perfect equilibrium of
Yin Yang reconciliation so I'm not one I
don't want to stay in my ego mind
I have the two
then the chi is circulating then it's
emanating then your energetic body is
actually being cultivated
so if you go too slow
I think you're going to be
operating too much in the egoic mind
okay just kind of go for it
but don't zone out because that's not it
either that's not an integration
okay let's go
okay so uh a question came up here but
you might find it interesting however
I'll preface this by saying this this is
not the beginner level stuff so you
stick to the shape shape I gave you okay
but I already mentioned that there's an
insight to the technique
um that is replicating concentrically
the shape which you're doing both
energetically and then physiologically
okay so you you have these kind of
levels and just for simplicity's sake uh
we'll call this the spirit level you
have an energy level
inner energy
and then you have a physical level
okay
here at your physical level uh is your
arm your hand and arm shapes okay
and your energy level is your yin and
yang
or in aikido's language is your I.T
and Coq
at the spiritual level using our
discourse you have your ego tripartite
mind
and your God mind
okay
all of these things are going to be what
I call reconciled or integrated
uh
if we have for example a spectrum
where you have Yin on one side
and Yong on the other
there is a point on this line
where it is neither Yin nor yang
it's perfectly reconciled
this is where you want to be
okay this is where your
in other words uh your hand shape is
your arm shape meaning you move your arm
in a way to keep your hand shape
and you form your hand in a way to keep
your arm shape there's they're not
fighting each other if as I watch some
of your techniques they're all fighting
each other the hand and arm are fighting
each other okay and then in the same way
uh
at the beginner level it appears clear
and begin hand young hand but as you
watch me going and she feels it she
can't tell which hand it doesn't feel
which hand is Yin and which hand is
Young either hand can throw her in
exactly the same energy that is
happening okay but inside at a deeper
level
you have this not I'm not hanging out in
some kind of like psychedelic High
that's not what's happening but I'm not
here either uh going uh it's a heart
pattern and draw yeah I'm not doing that
you can't do that okay there's an
integration of the two minds
why is it concentric
because it's happening like this okay so
we'll say We'll number them for a
reference sake
here's one
two
three
do you got it there there they're doing
the same thing what's the same thing
integration and Reconciliation or you
can call this centeredness or
Tranquility just understand it as The
Duality the dualism the dichotomy has
been reconciled
okay got it
that's all you're doing reconciliation
and Reconciliation reconciliation
to truly do
three and two
you have to do one it's not possible
but because it's concentric
and because it happens at the same means
three can lead to two and two can lead
to one
okay this is the whole uh
the whole nature of Taoist Alchemy
Buddhist uh soteriology
um
uh Christian Notions of Salvation it
that that the means can lead to the
source okay
not my experience I'm sorry it's not my
experience
I think that idea
is
the egoic mind
trying to understand what we just did
okay
this is the source
and you get yourself in the ballpark
hopefully the source happens but there's
a lot of teachers who go no no no do
three do two do one not my experience
okay
but
this is what we mean by concentric
a side note on kokudosa because
culturally
uh
you get something that in my opinion
negates the training
okay and the previous segments I was
using the phrase reconcile the conflict
do you remember that okay so uh if she
offers her hands and I go like this
there's no conflict
there's nothing
there's
I'm just holding on to her hands okay
um
the
the the the energy
that is assumed in the architectures of
aikido's kihonawaza
entails at a martial level the tactic of
spinal displacement
at a spiritual level
uke is being a sign or an energetic
level uke is being assigned
um young energy
and then
will reconcile the young energy with Yin
energy
and then transfer back to young as they
do the technique uh all the whole while
while their arms are moving in and young
okay so there is a yin and yang
relationship to Naga and UK as well and
when she offs her hands and I sit here I
have not done anything to generate a Yin
or a yarn here okay
so at the physiological level the tactic
that I'm using is spinal displacement so
and uh at an energetic level that is
called Q
okay and it is aimed into our Center it
looks like this
[Music]
that that is what I'm doing
I'm not
holding here in space because she can
just hang there and there's nothing to
do there right
um it is a micro drill it is not
scenario training it is not self-defense
training uh you're working in exactly
those elements that I described okay so
the goal of uke is first a prescription
I'll do it slower this time where you
are doing a Coq projection into our
Center
so as she goes that's what she's trying
to do right I am now going to reconcile
this by doing what we just described
okay so one hand will do the young hand
one hand is going to first go on the
inside so she pushes it goes on the
inside do you see her Energy's going
this way
this hand right is gonna go this way
boom
so if you pay attention it's very it's
very much what I'm watching even you
guys share is you don't have the little
bit of Yin and you're young and the
little bit of young in your Yin so you
go like this or you go like this but
you're pushing on that uh
young hand so she comes in and you push
right away there should be first a small
yield again if I'm trying to uh stir and
get as much juice right as much juice
from The Squeeze if I'm trying to
energize
um my yin and yang
aspects the more that I move rotate
again just superficially here the more
that I rotate that Hara the better so
when I just start here and this is now
my rotation not not I could do a little
more so boom
if you pay attention right as she goes
to grab
um
so watch how much movement it's not just
here and you go here that
there's a movement
I'm only interested in moving this thing
stirring the cheek
and in that
that's where she can't push on me okay
oh it's gone push boom so we can have a
stronger person
okay and he's going around I gotta get
rid of this thing first
you see
I'm not gonna go
ahead and try it again and young that
thing the very first part stir
so for me
um
you'll see that I don't just stir and
it's this is what I want to point out to
you guys here I don't you this is not
story
stirring makes a circle
which means my body has to go back to go
forward
do you understand so your hair and
you're like only stirring
two-dimensionally which I wouldn't call
stirring so as will rewind a little bit
more as he comes in you see how my body
is going back watch my body
and that's what gives you the inside
here is very hard to get on the inside
of both hands but in a circle very easy
foreign
so make sure you are finally displacing
and then
you use the stirring the taking the
energy level to its fullest right uh to
number three physiologically reconcile
the initial conflict which is prescribed
for the drill and assigned to UK
okay so uh for me and the way we often
train
uh that is kokudosa uh because we're
just micro drilling all those elements
that I just discussed but you can uh
there's nothing wrong with it is you'll
do that same thing and you'll come into
here okay and this is an ex as all
Aikido pins are there are a Coq drill
okay so here I'm not there's a little
Ike in here but it's really Coq okay uh
and then you can intensify it so she can
regain her position and what she is
going to try to do is push me over and
I'm not supposed to let that happen Okay
so I let the cheese sink and she pushes
as hard as she can and basically it
doesn't affect me at all okay and then
you repeat the drill
and you go to the other side Palm
in
and you again are just doing Coq Yoku
cultivation okay the shape however
is her hand is even with her head
so this is wrong and this is wrong her
hand is even with her head
and I have one knee at her armpit
and one knee at her wrist okay
don't bring your hands here under your
Center that's why you do both sides one
hand is out
and one hand is on that young line here
okay don't lean on them just stay over
yourself
and she goes
usually I you don't do it too long
because they get really tired and then
you come back
okay
here again
and you are in Kiza on the balls of your
feet never never like this
he's a
okay so both ways of training either
with kokuyoku at the end or just
continue to work the main elements of
all kihonawaza they're both fine in my
book